maintenant vous allez avoir un anti
portrait chinois
en revanche rares
andré glucksmann je vous étiez un défaut
vous soyez quoi moi on pire une injure
c'est c'est celui qui dit qui l'est
c'est une maladie se croire bon se
croire un très bon qui veut faire l'ange
fait la bête un accident le genre humain
une perversion un sandwich saucisse
nutella ou d'une glace vanille camembert
si vous étiez une guerre la prochaine
ou bien la guerre de tchétchénie qui
dure depuis 300 ans 1
mais plutôt du côté de chez jane soutien
vis un mont blanc mais pas le pape pas
la montagne une meringue avec un dan le
marron une crème chantilly c'est elle en
fait c'est la véritable madeleine de
proust âge et ça se vendait chez
rebelles meyer et le magasin a été
débaptisée par les nazis parce que ça ce
n'est pas vraiment tout à fait le
français vous étiez une trahison l'oubli
une arme les couverts en matière
plastique du vol mais qu'on a dit vous
étiez un supplice le match télévisé
juste un chien qu une cicatrice celles
qui ne se referme pas
ground zero sujet tient dictateur ou sur
les quais du but c'est une invention
d'un lycéen 1,88 à 15 ans en 1881 en
1888 qui anticipe et ben laden et polpot
et staline et hitler et qui en plus est
drôle si vous étiez une infirmité les
pieds dans le plat and assassins
raskolnikov mohammed atta rien de ce qui
est inhumain ne nous est étranger si
vous étiez un terroriste à un terroriste
qui réussit qui fait beaucoup de morts
qui est félicité par tout le monde qui
va boire le thé avec la reine
d'angleterre je serai là d'ymir bladimir
beach poutine public
chez robert laffont 2
à